more than a decade after the murder of a
local teenager the last suspect charged
in that death is going to be sentenced
davon phillips will be in court here in
just a few hours he is accused of being
part of an armed gang that robbed and
killed a 16 year-old local boy hector
mejia joins us now live outside the
courthouse downtown with the very latest
on the story hector
hey there in this case goes back to 2009
the victim's family says they hope to
get a degree of closure when devon
phillips finally gets sentenced at 11
o'clock this morning here at district
court and phillips is one of four men
charged with killing 16 year old eric
brill at a house party back in 2009 then
stealing 20 dollars and his cell phone
the case went cold until the men were
arrested seven years later phillips was
initially charged with multiple felonies
including assault robbery and voluntary
manslaughter police say brill and his
friends were outside of a party near
charleston and sloan when arthur moore
devonte wash devon phillips and nadim
hiko robbed them
brill was shot in the back of the head
while running away the other victim was
shot four times but survived in court
records show that phillips has entered a
guilty plea agreement we'll let you know
what happens in court again it gets
underway at 11 o'clock this morning in
downtown this morning hector mejia live
local now